wir wollen ja dass weihnachten
stattfindet ich weiß nicht ob alle es
geschafft haben die geschenke
rechtzeitig zu kaufen
ich habe vorhin gesagt lieber ein
bisschen mehr einschränken dieses jahr
und dann gutschein unterm weihnachtsbaum
legen und dann kommt der christ der
weihnachtsmann bringt den gutschein und
der wird dann eingelöst wenn es wieder
möglich ist
ich wünsche mir dass dies auf einige
jahre hin das letzte weihnachtsfest
vaters für unter so traurigen
bedingungen verbringen müssen
ich wünsche mir dass die familien
zusammenkommen können dort wo es
vertretbar ist dass niemand infiziert
wird und dass wir alle zusammen die
solidarität und die gemeinsamkeit
parteiübergreifend die heute sichtbar
geworden ist auch in den nächsten wochen
und monaten zustande bringen